what
do you think went wrong in regards to
your career and maybe just the whole
entire rough rider situation because it
definitely
there could have been worse situations
for you to be a part of at that time
because at that time that was the
that brand was scorching yeah i mean you
know
what like what
[Music]
a manager that was like fully behind me
franchise i said like i always shared
with dmx you found chances dmx was
like a real protector for me so i mean
you know
like his management i had that
management um
his movie agents i had those movie
agents
like i never really had like your own
people
okay i'm going home i never had a movie
agent that was like okay i'm going off
and just dragging
me out auditions for those parts because
x put a good word in from me like yo
i'm not going to shoot this example
unless you use drag on
ask my brother he looked like me that's
my homie it makes sense the vibe is
there
let's go and that's how i got that right
an excellent one
yeah you know what i'm saying but you
know that's how i got in that movie yeah
and then it led to another movie and
stuff like that you know i mean but
the reason why that style is because i
mean once something happened with him
as far as hollywood [ __ ] is out yeah
they they yes right it wasn't like there
was somebody else that could be like
okay
also those agents those managers
obviously dmx is going to be their
priority because at the time he's
probably bringing in
so much money you know what i mean what
he said what he said
30 over probably over 30 million records
just saying by himself
it's crazy i mean look you did have
a lot of people who we see come out of
crews that are you know are big like
that
don't get the chance to put out two
albums we see a lot of like
people who are get signed like think
about all the artists on roughriders
that never even dropped an album
there was a lot